[Música]
Donald Trump citado a declarar el comité
del Congreso de Estados Unidos que
Investiga el asalto al Capitolio del año
pasado llamó al antiguo mandatario a
entregar su testimonio los legisladores
quieren determinar qué hacía El Magnate
mientras ocurría el ataque
el presidente de México Pide a Estados
Unidos que restablezca relaciones
diplomáticas con Venezuela Andrés Manuel
López Obrador asegura que es un paso
necesario de cara facilitar la
repatriación de los migrantes
venezolanos que llegan de manera
irregular a la Unión Americana
se cumplen 40 años desde que Gabriel
García Márquez ganó el premio Nobel de
literatura es uno de los temas que
celebra este año el festival de
periodismo Gabo en su décima edición
tenemos análisis
Bienvenidos a una nueva franja
informativa aquí en la pantalla de
frases 24 Gracias por continuar con
nosotros Mi nombre es juanjopiales y
Estas son las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano a menos de tres
semanas de las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos el comité del
Congreso que Investiga el asalto al
capítulo del año pasado emitió una
citación para el ex presidente Donald
Trump quien estaba al frente del país y
en el momento del ataque precisamente
este viernes Steve vano Quien fuera un
importante helado del Magnate fue
condenado a prisión por no colaborar en
este caso
un nuevo golpe para Donald Trump el ex
presidente de Estados Unidos Fue citado
este viernes por el comité de
representantes para declarar sobre el
ataque del 6 de enero de 2021 al
Capitolio y le pidió proporcionar una
serie de documentos que van desde
comunicaciones personales entre el
republicano y miembros del Congreso
hasta información sobre sus contactos
con grupos extremistas en virtud de una
votación unánime el comité selecto
emitió una citación al expresidente
Donald Trump para que brinde testimonio
y registros relevantes para la
investigación del comité selecto sobre
el ataque del 6 de enero al Capitolio de
los Estados Unidos y sus causas Trump
deberá presentarse al Capitolio en
persona o en videoconferencia a partir
del 14 de noviembre y de ser necesario
durante varios días el comité también
señaló que los documentos deben ser
presentados antes del 4 de noviembre y
hasta el momento no está claro si el ex
mandatario aceptará la citación paralelo
a la orden de citación Steve banon uno
de los antiguos del ex presidente fue
sentenciado a cuatro meses de prisión y
Apagar 6.500 dólares por no acudir a
declarar sobre el mismo caso ante el
comité
tendremos un proceso de apelación
vigoroso para esta decisión tenga un
gran equipo legal y habrá múltiples
áreas de apelación Pero como dice ese
letrero a la derecha ahí podemos tener
el letrero de Voto el 8 de noviembre van
a tener un juicio sobre el régimen
ilegítimo de biden
habrá que ver si estos nuevos hechos
influirán en los resultados de las
elecciones de medio término en las
cuales los estadounidenses decidirán si
mantienen en El poder del Congreso a los
demócratas o si los republicanos podrán
tener más protagonismo y en la frontera
de México con Estados Unidos el número
de migrantes venezolanos que intentan
llegar a la Unión Americana sigue
aumentando por ello el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
pidió Washington que retomé relaciones
diplomáticas con Caracas y así poder
repatriar a los migrantes más fácilmente
en medio de la crisis de venezolanos que
intentan llegar a Estados Unidos México
está ejerciendo de muro de contención no
obstante con la migración alcanzando
niveles récord el gobierno mexicano
sugirió retomar relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y Venezuela rotas en 2019
es necesario
que
se restablezcan las relaciones de
gobierno de Estados Unidos y el gobierno
de Venezuela es indispensable la semana
pasada Estados Unidos anunció la
concesión de entrada humanitaria a
24.000 venezolanos en un intento por
frenar la oleada de migrantes que cruzan
de México a Estados Unidos la mayoría
después de una peligrosa travesía por
Centroamérica pero esta medida no parece
ser suficiente
este vamos a ir
solicitando que se entreguen más Y es
que tras un acuerdo con México los
venezolanos que cruzan ilegalmente a
Estados Unidos se exponen a ser
devueltos a suelo mexicano en una
estrategia muy similar a remake México
de la administración de Donald Trump en
Ciudad Juárez en las organizaciones
humanitarias esperan a los que han
corrido esa suerte para intentar
satisfacer sus necesidades básicas
algunos comentan que tenían dos tres
semanas sin bañarse
otros decían que tenían pues ya un
bastante rato sin comer bien o algunos
comentaban que les quitaron su calzado
cuando intentaron cruzar Y pues ahora
valoramos mucho más el calzado quizá que
la comida la falta de diálogo entre
Caracas y Washington complica la
repatriación de venezolanos para los
venezolanos era mucho más probable
quedarse en Estados Unidos hasta la
medida del 12 de octubre porque era muy
difícil devolverlos a Venezuela
77.900 millones de dólares Esa es la
suma acordada para invertir en proyectos
sostenibles en América Latina anunciada
en el cierre de la Cumbre mundial de
alcaldes c40 40 así lo dio a conocer
Horacio Rodríguez jefe del gobierno de
la ciudad de Buenos Aires quien fue el
anfitrión de este foro en el que
coinciden los gobernantes de cerca de la
100 ciudades más grandes del mundo esta
red se dedica sobre todo a combatir el
cambio climático sobre la ayuda para la
región acordada habló el alcalde de
Londres Se ha decano
no hay una buena razón por la cual la
comunidad internacional no pueda
mantener viva la promesa de 1.5 grados y
sin embargo este objetivo crucialpende
de un hilo porque a pesar de todo el
progreso que están logrando nuestras
ciudades
demasiados gobiernos nacionales están
dando largas negándose a comprometerse
con las políticas la regulaciones y de
energía limpia que sabemos que debemos
hacer para evitar un colapso climático
catastrófico
continuamos con nuestro cubrimiento
especial de Cara a la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales de Brasil
del próximo 30 de octubre las
universidades públicas brasileñas están
contra las cuerdas corren el riesgo de
no poder pagar a sus empleados durante
cuatro años de revolucionaron recortes
presupuestarios a la educación uno de
los focos más opositores al presidente
de ultraderecha veamos este informe de
nuestro equipo en Río de Janeiro
un antiguo hospital psiquiátrico
construido hace más de 120 años en la
universidad Federal de Río de Janeiro a
la que solo le queda esta escalera de
madera de su pasado esplendor;
es una falta de mantenimiento que
representa un peligro permanente para
estudiantes como Jessica piñeiro que
estudia ciencias sociales
toda la universidad está hecha de madera
Así que si hay un incendio se acabó
porque no hay una salida de emergencia
no hay un protocolo de vacunación
desde el comienzo de la pandemia también
se han suspendido miles de becas de
estudio e investigación sin explicación
alguna al igual que esta universidad
otras 68 se encuentran en situación
preocupante en Brasil de 2019 al 2022 el
presupuesto de las universidades
públicas federales se ha recortado en un
50%.
estos estudiantes han condenado al
fracaso las intenciones del gobierno de
privatizar su gestión instituciones
vistas como una amenaza por el gobierno
en las universidades han surgido los
mayores movimientos
antivulsionados en 2019 más de 100.000
estudiantes se reunieron frente a
nuestra universidad para protestar fue
la primera gran movilización contra
bolsonaro al inicio de la pandemia Así
que creo que siente que es un foro de
resistencia contra él por eso nos ataca
de vuelta tras bloquear más de 500
millones de euros del presupuesto
universitario federal Justo antes de las
elecciones Yair bolsonaro encendió la
llama
ese día miles de estudiantes se
manifestaron en Río una movilización en
las calles y en redes sociales que según
Jessica obligó al gobierno a dar marcha
atrás y congelar el presupuesto Solo
hasta diciembre cuando el pueblo sale a
la calle puede cambiar las cosas cada
vez que nos manifestamos conseguimos que
el Gobierno repele ya sea en la calle o
en redes sociales como Jessica estos
jóvenes estudiantes constituyen uno de
los focos electorales más importantes
para el candidato de izquierdas Lula que
ha prometido dar prioridad a la
educación y al acceso a la universidad
se gana Bogotá la capital colombiana es
por estos días de la sede de la décima
edición del festival Gabo una
celebración del periodismo
iberoamericano organizado por la
fundación homónima creada por el
fallecido Premio Nobel de literatura
Gabriel García Márquez hablamos
previamente con Daniel Manríquez
coordinador del festival Gabo con quien
abordamos el homenaje del festival por
los 40 años del premio Nobel de
literatura para Gabriel García Márquez
Pues yo creo que tuvo una gran
incidencia en la literatura Porque con
el premio Nobel a García Márquez entró
dentro de las bibliotecas podríamos
decir serias del mundo toda esa magia
que había en sus libros que era una
magia muy asociada a la realidad pero yo
creo que el impacto y el efecto del
Nobel de García Márquez no quedó
solamente en la literatura sino que a
través del discurso que pronunció en
estocolmo cuando recibió el premio tuvo
un impacto para la vida política y
social de la región Porque él fue quien
quien en ese discurso número Cuáles eran
las los retos los problemas pero también
las cualidades de todo el continente y
lo que lo unía y una identidad común no
Entonces yo creo que que García Márquez
No fue solamente un Nobel de literatura
sino algo mayor que trascendió a la
literatura
Nos despedimos la información continua
en esta pantalla también en Francia
24.com
[Música]